yeah hello welcome to this broadcast
this is number two there was some
something something wrong there that I
recognized but it should it should work
now okey dokey I'm looking forward to
play some blitz chess here in the five
minute pool on the NSSC been working all
day teaching chess but let's not stop
play some chess requesting for five
minute game and see what happens yeah
hello too many regulars that are there
are one who do we have
triple-check simon wells my Ponzi people
by Auschwitz igniting ideas ibrahim
scene 1995 couple of regulars yeah
welcome to all the last session has not
been yeah it wasn't great terrible is a
bit strong but it wasn't good big dark
decker hello yeah why is YouTube
supposed to be better than twitch yeah I
hope that we get to set up that I can
stream by YouTube no patch which and I
prefer that because you have them in
YouTube you can easily use the
announcement system so that you can
easily see when new broadcasts are
scheduled and I think this is working
better than twitch I mean of course I
know that you can also do that with
twitch basically but people need second
accounts on Twitch and everybody
basically has some has something for
YouTube and I would really like to only
have one platform so it will be a nice
also for my own streams I would I think
be more inclined to stream via YouTube
then why a twitch
my own on my own channel okay I'm going
to go here another question by igniting
it is is a difficult to study and in the
meantime I'm trying to get better and
chest I think we study he means going to
university well it depends a little bit
I think on yeah how much time and yeah
how much time at work you need to invest
for your studies I mean if you are able
to do that without completely I mean if
you have some some spare time left and
you don't want to finish your what you
do there in record time then I think
it's definitely possible even though if
you really want to be quick there and
not take ages with your with your stay
at University well yeah it's it's tricky
one thing that is quite um quite
important this you also have to be be
disciplined enough that you I mean if
you if you are there at university it
should make should make yeah you should
get anyway I should not take take a very
very long time with with your stuff and
you have to set some priorities there I
always had this problem I've been to
University for for about two two years
and my issue back then was that back
then was that I always preferred to do
chess and at the end I never got anyway
I am at the end I simply terminated the
whole business and started to ya learn
on the job in that in that Bank where
stayed for quite a long time so for me
studying wasn't wasn't that that easy to
do because chess always got in the way
somehow so you have to be careful them
that
it that did you actually get something
done okay
mmm how do i do this now i think i go
here you might have f6 actually hmm when
i control he ate anyway so this is not a
bad move
yeah I was thinking this but now I can
go here okay of course yeah he can he
can do that okay I have to take stuff
take b8 and hope that this is still okay
even though that wasn't the great
technical the greatest technical play
ever quite clearly let's see
we should age six hmm
yeah for I don't like that move and it
gets difficult really gets difficult how
to do that the only what I like is that
this Bishop h6 is not doing much maybe I
get rook c1 and get the C phone running
oh we have many gyro Netherlands Luciana
Bulgaria Norway that's great yeah hello
to our x1 3 3 8 I saw your I saw your
post on Twitch and on Twitch on on
reddit and I will definitely answer but
I didn't have yet didn't have time yet
with I didn't have time to to write some
kind of some kind of useful answer I
want to write it in a decent way and I
didn't have any time we'll probably do
that tomorrow morning okay I got to take
stuff here upped it to I think at the
end this should be okay
oh yeah I think I can still take more
stuff she's six I thought I can just
take them and give the exchange back or
maybe this is this is the wrong approach
now it should work I should be able to
get it at the end this thing and g3 it's
a it's just one pawn Wow okay I was
thinking I should be able to to enter
with the rook rook F 3 and so on
okay this it gets you get some kind of
play here right I don't I don't want to
get shake man yeah okay so I can promote
yeah okay that looks that looks fine I
think I win the H pawn him or the a pond
one of the two no Rx everything's cool
I mean your your post is totally fine
I'm just I just want to answer in a
decent way not in some kind of rushed
rushed manner and what is the worst
gambit the more I gambit or the gal
again but I think the gala gambit is
probably worse in the Slav
but did say it's tough it's tough so how
do I actually win that win at pawn this
may be you know come around
yeah I just get the apron okay he's
doing this should work though yeah I'm
blocking that deep on it's time to
resign for mr. Tully okey-dokey
so do one sketch oh yeah this airplane
this guy I play quite a bit in recent
times yeah can I do here maybe play this
one the the gala Gambon in the Slav is
worth playing according to the new I
don't think so actually I think this is
mostly a pawn down for not much well it
depends a little bit on them maybe on
the on the time control blitz maybe by
in tournament chess the gala gambit I
think is man wouldn't go for that there
are maybe maybe you can play some
sidelines in the gala again but this is
this is possible maybe but I don't think
the the main line
I'm quick and banning since they gave me
that rights I'm going to bend like no
tomorrow okay I'm happy that I get an A
for you I interesting suggestion some
chump some chest tempo tactics trainer
interesting we're an interesting idea I
should should do that maybe once in a
while again okay so what about this
Knight to e5 maybe yeah well some if
Simon Williams some features that in his
one of his DVDs I mean the gallic gambit
is probably a little bit more a little
bit still sounded than the King's gambit
and he also has done videos on that I
believe ships should be five if that's a
move that I should have thought about a
little bit but Quincy to I don't know if
this is the the right answer I thought
this is kind of interesting
okie-dokie how do I do this now Queen to
c3 maybe or what is the point
I wonder if I can go a3 Andrew K for
maybe let's do that
let's take that pawn a little bit and
let's avoid irritating me maybe I can
give more support raid form maybe in the
gamma-gamma in the slap you can play
sidelines but the old main line I think
is really just a pawn down but in blitz
chess the gala gambit in the Slav can be
tricky I definitely know I have looked
at the Slav mainline and they had this
on the board sometimes and I didn't
score well simply because the practical
difficulties are quite clear okay
man's not so easy p7 just hangs how do I
cover that ok sound the screen to be six
like him I cannot remove the bishop
cannot move it away Wow
and I need a move I just don't see him
yeah this is bad I don't see movie Queen
b6 is good but yeah I am he's seeing it
of course I didn't see anything I didn't
see a reply
even at night at five and now Wow
they totally killed me he totally killed
me or kills me the game is still going
on okay maybe some age five business I
don't know I was expecting Knight c4 of
course somehow he didn't play that well
well
threatening b5 now and Roxy for he's got
cream b8 but still yeah I can take here
for that made on the back rank roopd to
Roxy one Bishop f1 Bishop h3
yeah yeah I got I got that Negro
technican here this very lucky and he's
made it very lucky yeah but sometimes
one trick is enough to win whoo I was
completely outplayed by mr. Scotto or
what the name is okay next one yeah in
fact I've lost against him before I
don't think I have a good score do I see
that score some oh yeah I'm not so much
familiar with Blitzen but I don't think
my score is any good yeah I did meet
Wolfgang woman once I mean I cannot
really say that I know him but I met him
once he was the guest of honor
for the 2000 the German championships in
the year 2000 and he was attending the
the closing ceremony and he was involved
in choosing the beauty prize which of
course I did not win because I did play
a very boring event and mostly played
bad clips but he was attending and we
only had a couple and a couple of words
if we felt it felt like a very nice
person to me yeah I'm I'm very much
looking forward to see how the voting
ends for my opening the openings on
reddit what the heck is this by the way
am i not just winning stuff I tried to
win stuff here
don't one Knight f5 to happen this is
why I take here first and now take the
pawn yeah woman woman is still playing
occasionally but he's got health
problems and he cannot cannot play that
frequently anymore I mean is his in his
is he 18 years old now close to that but
he played a game in the German
Bundesliga in fact not too long ago and
had a very decent game I think he
actually won his game against a good
player
so yeah in fact this game is also kind
of crazy he's getting f4 in that guy and
it really started weird for him but he
there formed a foursome is dangerous
definitely the energy for Scot f5 hmm
how do you do that that doesn't look
good
maybe this one yeah woman is a
well-known expert on the French defense
and also on the English opening as
someone said here he was always great in
the English opening so him Bishop h6
maybe him hmm
yeah whoo - is the main example of a
player with a very narrow opening
repertoire he's played the same stuff
his whole career and yeah if you watch
that now our broadcast here and wondered
what what this opening reddit stuff is
all about I agreed to do an opening some
some videos on on an opening in the
third week of January and I'm put out a
poll I'm mispronouncing that I'm aware
of it but I cannot do any better
yeah to choose to choose something and
if you have not yet voted make sure to
go to that page and vote okay so I'm a
I'm an exchange down here in this game
and I still have some hopes maybe
unfounded
yeah you can also play with the very
narrow repertoire nowadays but it
depends a little bit on what level
certainly not on the top 10 level yeah
of course white is probably winning here
what what can you do still hope for some
some mistakes yeah unfortunately um yep
my bishop on e4 is still a pretty decent
piece so it's not entirely hopeless I
think
so let's see is it may be possible to
still fight him maybe be 5
now that's not bad it's not bad at all
hmm okay they have to Wow
very fast this guy hmm
there should be five I can take this is
still a little trick take and Bishop e6
so as long I have some stupid little
tricks at hand I'm going to I'm going to
try now now he is thinking this is not
fair smelled red
okay okay I cannot take so go here and
maybe I've worked g8 now yeah it's
probably still totally lost but I mean
hey it looks like oh and now I can take
right I can take B should be six why
isn't that good or is that like a king
of two still and it's working at is
working for him
okay I can check on g8 group g3 and then
see okay that's not going to it's not
working unfortunately now this is
probably giving better chances
yeah plural apiece please suggestion
please suggest things other than playing
playing here rook g8 there was rook g3
still I'm open to ideas what else to do
in this stream I'm really open to that
and maybe maybe ICC is interested in in
those ideas I also met Robert Huebner
yeah that was a very memorable
experience this was actually when I
played the 1998 German championships
when I was very delighted to be seated
on the same on the same table as Huebner
was in the in the in the closing
ceremony and that was a very interesting
experience see he yeah he gave us some
information about his ideas of yeah
learning learning languages learning
Chinese playing Chinese chess and so on
very interesting personality c5 is
tricky now okay I think I can take and
now we get to get to the point where my
bishop said pawns are pretty strong okay
I can take stuff I'm winning now I
completely completely swindled that guy
totally swindled him yeah he resigned
boo-boo-boo yeah I agree I like that
session I love to play against the
five-minute poor morning playing cubed
so see on the as you see there's this
format is also already on I am major
Benjamin and I think Ronan is also doing
this okay playing key one here
t1 is that a good moment to go to what
is this actually
it's that a good moment to ask if this
is female or male this handle hmm yeah I
think we are pretty flexible what we do
with this hour I also intended or a
thought about doing a show where you can
send me questions beforehand that I can
answer
also with puddings putting things on the
board what I'm talking about is if you
ask me like what what plan should white
play in this particular structure or
yeah you sent me a position this like
this this is what I had in our team
match last Sunday and I didn't know what
to do is there particular idea that you
have or something like that this is
something that I also find an
interesting idea the looking at yeah
specific opening questions there is
already a show by by by John Watson this
is basically comparable to the to the
opening clinic that yang Gustavson is
doing for chess 24 what what what John
is doing
yeah quindi three are covering c3 the
endgame clinic help listen all I have to
have to prepare for that
I definitely not going to do an endgame
clinic the thing is what you have to
take into account is that this is
happening late in the evening in Germany
and I'm I'm already after I have had a
long and a long day of work after behind
me I have worked quite a bit this is
this day and what I need to do here is
something that is yeah it should be a
little bit light-hearted I don't want to
do something super you know super
sophisticated unfortunately I'm not
winning this year would be cool but I
don't
yeah I'm playing for 95 and Bishop b1
and stuff like that
okay what are you going to do now to
again quote Guns'n'Roses where do you go
now people like that I try to sing a
sing a little bit of all that song where
do you go now I cannot really sing I
won't try okay but when I will try it
I will try to use that rukia in a very
aggressive fashion look to H for mr. ki
Wang and the time is fine the time is
actually totally fine
I just don't want to do something super
sophisticated so G fork hmm M what the
heck
G for Queen back and you say this is all
cool right
this is what is saying
I probably blunder stuff
I take if I take this I can actually
take this right no I cannot my 95 yeah
was my original idea but this is a total
mess somehow I still do that Knight to
d6 okay whoa okay I will take things now
him I want some some kind of clarity in
this position if possible you cannot
play rook the age I mean yeah I'm
covering this so back I've got 95 coming
so 95 or something else
I think 95 is okay
it's not ideal here right
it's not an ideal position it's got Roxy
to endure coming here and there not so
great
that didn't work out well it's a it's
not I mean I I wouldn't I wouldn't mind
to play holy gasps I really don't
I mean I've developed a somewhat
different approach to that with my quick
play and like the what the heck attitude
but he simply does not play that time of
day
before hangs huh
tough tough position
ya know I got got some get those pieces
going somehow I just not so clear and
what the ultimate goal for them is the
rook here is the problem
Ruka she does f4 I have to do this I
guess and then get the rook rook h3 g3
yeah I can take f2 I need some some play
on my own here with 26 seconds it's
basically yeah made or die something
like that between these six probably mmm
it's not what is that I don't get that
one I'm covering c1 here it said one of
the sessions where I play nonsense but
sheet myself out of it all of the time
hmm maybe maybe not
he has to do that it might be enough
might might be just enough yeah yeah
he's probably smelling me well that's
lucky he didn't he didn't see that
before and I'm very sure about it maybe
it's not meeting me where are you
meeting me I don't have one you know
well so oh no no that's that's a cool
opponent what are you doing in the chat
and playing okie dokie we got colors
what are you doing against the against
the Berlin let's see yeah it's not very
inspiring yeah I did watch naka versus
Komodo a little bit yep I actually think
that it was interesting much first of
all it was interesting and they're like
the the general idea of those matches
however one thing that I absolutely
believe us that the they played four
games and the fourth game what was
Nakamura with with two extra with two
extra moves I think it was yeah like
additional development in a way and I
think that this is actually very I mean
of course it is an advantage for the
human player that additional development
but it is very very tough I mean this is
not not that great is what I'm trying to
say and I think that the the other the
other handicaps
they were far more serious I mean a pawn
is something yeah and they at the pawn
that the exchange I think it must be
material and that that there's just a
couple of moves is not enough to make it
some kind of a fair thing I mean I think
the computer has a heavy heavy favorite
with this extra moves
I actually to be perfectly honest I
think with the material handicaps
you don't need to be as good as Nakamura
to play against against the engine to be
honest I feel very confident that I
could do stuff against it I'm really
sure
with the f7 and so on I'm not sure I
would be very tempted to try that but
the extra moves is really that's not
much I mean it's nice against human
especially but against the computer hmm
I feel like this is not such a serious
serious handicap okay I'm a piece up
here against Filner and I don't see much
compensation coming his way
my knight is will go to e7 to g6 this is
the idea maybe you should take it player
for something like that
I think Nakamura did very well in the
other in the other in the other in the
first three three games but the fourth
handicap is too tough it's too tough
I mean they put up a very good fight in
that game but now I think that the
computer has a heavy favorite want to go
to g6 to finally get neither foreign
thing come over one by one point
yeah no no neither four is some needs to
be taken into account
his skin check on his seven but I've
queen f so well that might have said
that said some kind of perpetual that
would be a bit of a shame I really don't
want to draw this game being a piece of
whoa
doesn't do it 97 was good I think no I
didn't I didn't watch the programmers
interview
I understand that that Larry Kaufman is
very proud of his creation but I say I
think he largely overestimates what the
engine can do give it give it some some
stupid Kings Indians and the human still
beats the engine senseless it's just
what it is
of course as as soon as the position is
opened its opening up and it gets
tactical the computers is playing God
like but yeah I could get a good game I
think you could have played 27 fluid
that was sauce very much possible okay
yeah so playing the psychopath
psychopath is that should I be worried
they're playing the psychopath cycle
would be a five now yeah okay
yeah good move Bishop F a just back
King f1 is the best line against Bishop
before chicken I mean the thing is I
don't think that the computers are
always too made it I don't know don't
underestimate it at all I think the
thing is the thing is that there are
still lots of positions where the
computer understands absolutely nothing
and and until they I mean we can talk
again if those positions are evaluated
correctly by the engine if someone is
interested I can make a video and one
time to show you like four or five
positions where the computer doesn't get
anything right there they are plenty of
those in end games and middle games and
so on yeah this was also played verge by
Julian against Nigel short but it's not
I didn't copy it from from her but I I
have played this opening with black over
the years on and off and this is a
problem Lion King f1
no I wanted kf3 okay it doesn't matter
that much I lose stuff yeah sure
I know you're right the number of
positions is dis is decreasing they're
just a very specific set of positions
some end games and so on but it's still
there
see six isn't that good for me to open
the C file what I want to prevent is
some wacky sacrifice on g4 right okay
that's not going to happen
the night is on g3 now that's good and
go before
yeah I think the percentage of positions
where the human is better than the
engine is it's something like clearly
clearly below 1% it's zero point
something just a very very small range
of positions where the engine is not
getting it right I mean this position
for example is terrible for black not
sure how bad the engine this would I bet
an engine this would evaluate it's clear
that you would give white a clear
advantage but I'm not sure how much and
I think white will win this with good
plane
zero-point-six by Houdini interesting
and I wouldn't version though yeah it's
more than 0.6 not sure how much but it's
the kangaroo variation what is that
I mean you mean the tango this is also
called the kangaroo yeah well this
position is a long suffering for black
maybe he can hold but it's it's not
exactly what I would call fun
so we're maybe can indeed what it looks
it looks pretty awful but still
I don't know if you can go f5 but I can
directly enter them probably cannot play
a five okay kangaroo is yeah I know I
mean this is an old version of Houdini's
still so interesting to hear okay the
big issue is and what is about what it's
night p5 he is said winning or not well
it's just a blitz game so let's go for
it
night a for yeah it didn't lead to much
right I didn't see what it leads to
King
oh well that could be a drop could be a
draw really it's not I cannot really get
anywhere here even King even King F is
not doing much
now I can't do much there I think this
is more more or less a clear draw huh
that's a bit of a shame any other way is
to do something here with two nights
says something to do where I can do it
two nights sacrifice on c5 mmm not going
to work coming around not going to work
I trade it too much I'm sure I traded
too much I guess
not no idea okay I'm offering a draw him
yeah that's a shame
that's a shame
yeah okay one more game yeah night to be
six he just ignores it and Moscow homie
I cannot pronounce that I always have
boil against him so I'm kind of not used
to playing black against this person I
did I had the CIA takes with the night I
think if I take on before or is it
something like that he plays this
variation
yeah what what am I playing here I have
no idea I think I try to eat five ones
but that is also Promenade bad I had
problems with that I had problems with
that in earlier videos I'm pretty sure I
did a chess variants not I haven't
planned anything it's difficult to get
opponents for most of them in the first
place and I won't play the super crazy
ones like a tomake or things like that
yeah
streaming bullet tournaments that will
largely depend on if I can stream on
YouTube or not if I can I will probably
stream a little bit more I think it's
just a bit more more comfortable to do
but I will definitely not do much in the
next like two weeks or so I mean next
week Reich is starting and Reich and Z
is starting or Tata Steel it's what is
normally called nowadays and I will do
some coverage on my channel I will cover
something on the ICC and I also have
some other things to do and at that time
I would definitely not play any chess
variants or bullet or whatever covering
Tala still is some work anyway
whyever why do I have such a bad
position yeah yeah I played it badly
right against Knight XD 4head such a
super harmless move at least it feels
very harmless
now I see porn isn't much yeah not fun
to have some a for I don't know
the autocracy will be an interesting
tournament I'm really looking forward to
that also because it is more of a mixed
bag it's not the same people all over
again I mean of course there are some
regulars we've got cars and I think
Khurana is playing and so on but there
are also a couple of not so as some
people competing they are not playing in
all of the events for example it will be
very interesting to see how who you find
is doing the she's not the woman world
champion at the moment right that's
Maria Musa choked but she's the best
female player so I'm looking forward to
that for example the best line from
black against the French Terrace stuff
to say what's the best line is I think
if you want something interesting to
play you can check out 96 this is an
interesting line maybe not the best line
but it is something that will irritate
white players quite a bit I'm kind of
curious this guy's playing this very
technically in a very technical way that
really that that much yeah of course
also looking forward to the candidates
that will be an highlight of course
yeah I haven't seen that John Watson
show for two or three weeks no no no
maybe even longer maybe he's taking a
break I don't know it's not it's not on
at the moment it's usually on on
Tuesday's swiftlets chant is any
candidates yeah he certainly yeah must
be qualified as a dark horse but you
never know I mean I actually believe
that he was playing very well in the
candidates in London in 2013 and it was
I mean he was also not playing badly
like what was that in in 2014 not bad
there he was very well prepared and yeah
I mean always must be dark horse but I
don't know there are there are
everybody has got some chances mr.
Moscow homie whatever has gone into some
self pin is that really the way to play
it I have my doubts there 95 years 95
I'm not going to do that
and now he's in this this weird self pin
95 or 96 meaning don't believe this
nonsense don't give me that crap
he said I'm pinning with this funky
tactic oh my god
no not come on King Gianna and now he
trades heavens heavens I'm playing this
like a god damn [ __ ] oh my goodness I
hate it
I should never lose the game after the
self pin absolutely never ever that was
so bad okay
that's a complete loss and a complete
loss it's not even possible to fight
really
now kick him out that's useless Wow
oh my goodness that was thoughtful so
unnecessary right how did I he gets into
this bloody self pin and then many kind
of tricks me to know and this is
unbelievable stuff 95 and it's as it is
really in the position it really is I
have no I have no way to avoid that this
is the crazy thing
maybe you just played it in a genius way
I don't know okay anyway it's six
minutes past I am when I started later
okay let's do one more there's requests
for one more and I don't mind that one
come on and let's beat this guy him dren
master tool Cass who is that
Florian Honka okay we actually played
not a little plane but I played as team
just a couple of weeks ago so what do we
get here some kind of our double
fianchetto that's actually interesting
line for black hmm I don't know it well
the can Scottie form might be for you
hmm interesting
d5 probably b5 are some some stuff like
that I don't know this is a somewhat
somewhat strange strange variation
I think they sometimes make they played
in the style of them of the Bangko quite
often cannot I cannot play Bishop f4 yet
a little bit of an annoyance okay I go
here see to try to make b5 difficult and
cover the b-pawn so let's try for Bishop
to c3 trade this strong Bishop shouldn't
be a bad bad position
I will definitely shoot for Bishop h3 I
think in the future to threaten 92 okay
took it and b5 hmm okay
Bishop age 3 I wonder how he reacts to
that maybe it just takes it on f3 and
now I will try to push on the against
that e7 pawn he's got look before coming
things like that but the e-file is not
bad not bad to have an f4 f5 h4 h5
things like that let's pile up
it's not much fun there for black I
think this position I cannot take
unfortunately one f6 it looks it's
closed r / k f FY 5
it's still close in the capture I came
oh I didn't think about that move at all
it's that good Queen d2 and stuff
I need h4 though I need a neat edge form
in this as an option I mean maybe Queen
d7 though huh huh I actually have a good
plan Bishop before Bishop c2 interesting
I don't I didn't expect that at all I
thought after this he has no good way to
cover that niche form it's going Queen
before here or maybe
yeah if six looks looks quite
straightforward down or Bishop before
maybe f6 Knight takes takes takes Queen
g5 stakes on c4 I don't want to give
them any material here really really
don't maybe I can prepare that even more
wow that seems tough too tough to
survive
a bishop comes to g6 I don't I would be
very surprised if black can survive that
now that'sthat's it I don't I don't I
don't see him surviving this I don't see
him surviving this bishop she's six
I would love to of course enter with the
Queen how to outer enter with the Queen
if I can to e4 to g4 and so on this is
the way to enter
yeah
Queeny six is also pretty good good that
I see this idea
it seems pretty strong queenie 6 up to
took me a while to that side yeah to his
six is pretty strong okay so i had a
good a good finish there with this game
nice controlled squeeze him okay thanks
i hope you enjoyed the stream it was a
mixed bag I had to swindle out of some
pretty bad positions but managed and
some of them I hope you enjoyed it was a
little bit a little bit longer than
planned but it doesn't really hurt to do
a couple of extra minutes I guess okay
thanks a lot guys I'll be back next week
I guess bye bye